welcome to
part four of the tutorial on
pseudo-boolean solving and optimization
this is part of the boot camp
for the program satisfiability theory
practice and beyond at the simons
institute for the theory of computing
previously in part one we defined what a
pseudo-boolean formula is it's a
collection of
zero one integer linear inequalities
in part two we discussed pseudo boolean
solving which is the problem of deciding
feasibility of such pseudo-boolean
formulas is their
zero one assignment satisfying all of
these linear inequalities
and we discussed method of solving this
by using
ideas from conflict driven closed
learning
sat solvers either you could rewrite
your pseudo boolean formula
to conjunct in normal form to cns and
run a cdcl solver
or you can keep the pseudo-boolean
formula but try to lift
the conflict-driven techniques
to native pseudo-boolean reasoning
then in part three we added a linear
objective function
and that and you want to minimize um
so you want to find a solution that
satisfies your formula but minimizes
this linear objective function
discuss different ways of doing this
using
ideas from max at solving
for instance and we saw some examples
of experimental results for different
implementations
and in these experimental results we saw
that apparently mixed integer linear
programming solvers are also fairly good
at sudo boolean optimization problems
um providing some fairly stiff
competition
and so in this fourth
and final part of the tutorial we'll
look a bit
more closely at these mixed interior
linear programming solvers
how they work and what they do
and whether we can maybe borrow some of
these techniques
to improve our pseudo boolean solvers
and maybe
export some pseudo boolean solving
techniques
potentially to make a mixed integer
linear programming solvers better
so a big caveat here
is that i am not
certainly an expert on mixed injury
linear programming
so this you should view this as a very
biased
survey a personal take of this material
as i try to learn it
enough to make use of it in my own
research so i'll try to tell you a
little bit of my understanding of mixed
inter-linear programming map
and integer linear programming ilp
and and then uh tell you uh
about some ideas for combining
pseudo-boolean solving and mip
techniques
uh why this is not maybe so easy to do
but
i'll also tell you about some ideas that
seem to work
i'll report on a case study on some
research
that we have done on this and then as in
the
previous parts of this tutorial i'll
throw out i'll try to highlight
a number of open problems
and research directions
so what is a mixed interlinear program
we have an objective function summing
over j a
j x j for variables x j we want to
minimize this subject to
a bunch of linear constraints
a i j x j summing over j less than equal
capital a i
and if you have watched the previous
tutorials you know that
in the pseudo boolean setting we love
normalized form where we always want
greater than but it seems that mid
people tend to write their programs with
less than or equal
so um in this part of the tutorial will
defer
to mip standard and use less than or
equal some of the time
so the variables are some of them are
integer valued
but there are also potentially some real
valued variables we think of all
variables as being non-negative
and as we already said we have linear
constraints on a linear objective
function
except that if there are no real valued
valuables
then we have an integer linear program
if in addition all
variables are bounded between 0 and 1 we
have a 0
1 integer linear program and a zero one
integer linear program that is just
a pseudo boolean formula and if
we have a vacuous objective function
say summing over j zero times x j
then that's just a pseudo-boolean
formula a decision
problem and we can feed such problems to
mip solvers but they seem to be best
for optimization problems where the
objective function can really
drive the search
two interesting difference compared to
the sat and sudubuna communities
is that firstly in the sat community it
seems that
essentially the best solvers are in
academia or at least
even if the big corporations maybe have
their own solvers they
not they're not fundamentally different
they're not doing something
fundamentally better
than what we know in academia
however in the mixed engineer linear
programming
community this is not so close
source commercial solvers such as cplx
grobbie and express are arguably
much better than the best academic
solvers
although a solver like skip is still
it's academic
you can it's not fully open source but
you can at least read the source code
and understand what it
does but
but it's not as good as the best
commercial solvers
and this also of course is challenging
when you try to evaluate
and run experiments because you would
like to run experiments with the best
solvers
but it's hard to interpret this these
results because you have no idea what
these solvers are doing or maybe
sometimes you have some idea but
but not not really enough so this is a
challenge
uh when running experiments and
evaluating meep solvers
another difference which is more about
solving technology
is that at a high level you can say that
the in
for saturn and pseudo-boolean solvers
the search phase where you make
decisions and propagations
there's a great emphasis on speed you
try to make your decisions as
quickly as possible you unit propagate
as quickly as possible
just go fast fast fast and then until
you hit a conflict and then you back up
then you go slow you do a sophisticated
conflict analysis you really
you're willing to invest some effort in
this because you want to learn
a good constraint that will guide the
search
going forward in mip solvers
it's pretty much the other way around uh
mixed integer linear programming solvers
can invest lots and lots of time and
effort
into decisions how to set
variables to values or or how to bound
decide on bounds for the variables
and in comparison the backtracking part
is not so advanced
so at a high level what a mip solver
does it
does some pre-processing of the input
it's called pre-solving
and then it repeatedly solves uh linear
programs uh that gives
estimates of what the solution might be
and this is called branch and bound
and then you can also add
new linear inequalities that are
known as cutting planes and they
are valid so they preserve
all the solutions to your original
problem but they can be used to rule out
infeasible solutions found by the linear
programming solver and so they
tighten the search base and then there
are lots of heuristics in particular
heuristics for how to solve
um because in in contrast to you can
think of of
sat and sudo boolean solver as going
depth first always you in your search
tree
but this is not so um in
uh mip solvers you can grow your search
tree in a much more
varied way maybe sometimes go deep and
sometimes you go
more do like breadth first search or or
some kind of combination
okay so what is a linear programming
relaxation well
you just keep your mixed internal linear
program
and the only difference is that
the integral variables are relaxed to be
real value
so this means that you can solve the
problem fast now it's just linear
programming this we can do in polynomial
time and you get
a linear programming solution which
we'll denote as x star
and this clearly gives a lower bound
because you're optimizing
over a bigger search space now so you
could potentially get a better minimum
and the lower bound you get is
definitely a lower bound on what you
could achieve
over the smaller domain it could happen
though
that this solution is happens to be
feasible for the original mip and if so
you're happy then you have an optimal
solution
as a side note the lp solver that you're
running
is i said we can solve this in in
polynomial time
and we know that you can solve linear
programs in in guaranteed polynomial
time using these
new sophisticated like ellipsoid based
methods
typically this is not uh what you'll be
using you'll use the old and trusted
simplex algorithm
the reason for this is that you will
have many many lp calls
on very similar problems where you just
change some variable bounce
and so you can reuse earlier work and do
so called hot restarts
to find the solution that might be very
close just a few pivots away
from where you were earlier and this is
something that is supported by simplex
but not by these more advanced modern
lp solving methods
so in branch and bound you somehow
choose
an integer valued variable xj in some
intelligent way
and some bound b some integer and then
you solve
the mip with the added constraint that
either x j should be greater than or
equal to b
and that gives you one sub problem and
the other sub problem is that it should
be smaller than or equal to b
minus one
and in this way you can get a
tree of sub problems which you can then
solve in the same way
and you can prune away a sub problem or
a node in your branch and bound tree
when you find out that the lp is
infeasible
or for instance when you have you you're
keeping track of the current best
solution the incumbent solution and if
you solve an
lp bound in a node and already that lp
bound
is larger than your incumbent then you
know you don't need to explore
this node or the search tree any further
branching decisions as you can see above
they're made on variables in general
you could also imagine branching on on
general linear constraints
this is potentially much more powerful
but it's also
difficult because it's difficult to
figure out
what kind of integer
linear inequalities you might want to
branch on a side note for
theoreticians in it mo in its most
general form
um this branching on general linear
inequalities corresponds to the
so-called
stabbing plane's proof system and a big
question
in in proof complexity is to understand
the power of this proof system it's very
powerful
much more powerful than the cutting
plane's proof system that we have been
talking about before
but again this assumes that you can
branch over general linear inequalities
which
in practice is not done
so the cutting planes method is
something that we should talk about
carefully one one
problem when you talk to people in the
mic
community is that the words
we use on the theory side maybe and on
the sat side
and some of the words they use for
instance when we talk about cutting
planes the cutting planes proof system
the cutting planes method
we typically mean different things so
that's important to keep in mind
so what is meant with the map
cutting planes method is basically this
so you solve an lp relaxation of your
problem
and again if if your solution happens to
be feasible for the mip then you're
happy because you found the optimum
but otherwise you add some
in some way you generate a constraint
sum over j b j x j less than b that is
valid for your original problem but is
violated
by this solution that you found because
this
allows you then to rule out the solution
and next time you call the lp solver it
will have to find some other solution
you repeat this over and over again
what could these cut rules be well for
those of you who have watched
uh previous parts of this tutorial the
rules we had in pseudo-boolean solving
the division rule and the saturation
rule
are examples of cut rules that would cut
away
um fractional solutions
to linear inequalities in fact that is
why it's so
important during pseudo boolean conflict
analysis that we use
division or saturation because that's
the only way
we can get truly boolean recently
and we'll talk in a minute about some
other cut rules
so the branch and cut method then is
that you
run this branch and bound that we just
talked about this branch and bound
method
but in each sub problem not only do you
call the lp solver but you repeatedly
take the solution add a cut and then
solve an lp again
add a new cut so that you tighten the
polytope
describing your problem and get rid of
more and more
non-integral solutions
for an interior linear program
okay so let's see an example of a cut
which is a knapsack cover cut suppose
that you have a constraint sum
over j in some set
index set i um aj
xj less equal
capital a and let's assume here that all
the
a's are integral they're positive
integers and
that the xj are boolean variables so
binary variables
then if we find a minimal cover of this
index set
so some set c such that if i
sum up all the aj's in c
i exceed a but any element in c that i
remove
and i sum over the rest and i don't
exceed a that's a minimal cover
and then if you think about it you
realize that if
the constraint here at the top of the
slide is supposed to be valid then
in particular when i sum up
um over the js
i cannot uh
pick more so this is a
a
[Music]
typo i think so this should sum up over
j in
c um
and i cannot sum more than
uh than at most c minus one of them or i
would exceed the bounds sorry for this
typo
um so going back to cutting planes how
would you derive this
well you would
in normalized form this constraint is
summing over
j and i aj x j bar greater than or equal
to minus a plus the sum of all
coefficients
and you can weaken this to remove
everything
except c and then you can divide to get
a disjunctive clause that says that
for one of the negated literals have to
be true
so um another
quite interesting and intriguing and
harder to understand cut
is what is called mixed integer rounding
so i'll just
i'll go fairly fast and won't explain so
you can hit the pause button in the
video and look at it it's an ugly
expression
or at least a confusing and hard to
understand expression suppose
suppose i'm stating it for a normalized
pseudo-boolean constraint
a i l i greater equal a so all the
a i's and a are positive integers
l i are literals over zero one valued
variables and suppose we do a mixed
integer around and cut with divisor d
that produces the following constraint
every li gets the following coefficients
so we take the minimum
over a i modulo d
and the degree of falsity a modulo d
plus a i divided by d rounded down
times a modulo d
summing over this this is what we do for
every li
greater than equal and on the right hand
side we get
a over d rounded up
again times a mod d
and somehow the magic and the mystery
here is in this min term where you can
choose the minimum between
a i and a mod
d so it's easier to look at a small
example if
if we do a mere cut for for the
constraint
say x plus 2y plus 3z
plus 4w plus 5u greater equal 5.
uh then the mere cut
says that well x plus 2y plus 2z
plus 3w plus 4u greater equal
4. so if you look at this it basically
says
in terms of weakening it says that you
can
weaken z from three to two you can also
weaken w
from four to three you can weaken
u from five to four and if we did this
with weakening then normally the five
here would drop to
two but the meerkat says that
no as you weaken you're losing at most
one unit here
so it's maybe instructive to compare
this
to standard division that we've talked
about before
if we just divide by three
then the dividing by three
five divided by three and rounding up
gives it 2.
so let's divide by 3 and then multiply
by
2 so that we get the same degree of
falsity
on the right hand side and if you do the
math you see that
standard division by 3 and
multiplication by 2 produces the
constraint
2x plus 2y plus 2z
plus 4w plus 4u at greater equal 4.
and if you compare this with the mere
cut you see
that the mere cut is stronger
sorry here is the mere cut it's stronger
because we have the same degree of
falsity here
but all the coefficients here are less
than or equal than their counterparts
here so this is a stronger constraint
than this one
and this is a general fact that anything
you can do with the
the division rule that we find in the
theoretical computer science literature
the proof complexity literature
you can do with mere cuts
and it's actually an interesting
question and i don't know the answer to
this how
the theoretical computer science the
proof complexity
kind of means division rule compares to
the mixed integer
rounding cut rule this would be
interesting to understand better
so next just a few words about
pre-solving that's a
topic for a completely wholly separate
talk
that goes for for many other topics in
this whirlwind
tour of of mip solving um
interestingly it is important for
performance but my impression is that
it's
not as crucial as for cdcl solvers which
like nobody in their
same mind would would run a cdcl solver
i think without pre-processing
for mip it's certainly important but
it's not a life or
death question as far as i've seen
some simple techniques that are used if
if you figure out that a variable is
fixed you can just substitute the value
there's some normalization of constraint
for instance if there's an integer
constraint you can find the greatest
common divisor
on the left hand side you can divide and
then round on the right hand side
you can probe by tentatively assigning
binary variables and propagate to see
what you find out
you can by dominance you can remove
constraints that are
implied by other constraints to shrink
the instance
and already in
part one of this tutorial i talked about
additional material
on mixed integer linear programming in
particular
for pre-solving there's more details in
the talk by ambrose kleczner and here
you have the
the link to this talk again
mixed interlinear programming solvers
also do conflict analysis
um and it's analogous
to what's being done in conflict-driven
close learning such soldiers in fact i
would argue that it's too analogous
in the sense that and in contrast to
native pseudo-boolean solvers what you
do is you
operate on reason
clauses that you extract from the
constraints but
um if you remember in in in part
two of this tutorial for pseudo-boolean
solvers they actually do the conflict
analysis directly
on the linear constraints themselves but
mib solvers don't do this
mib solvers only operate on clauses that
you can somehow derive
from the constraints and this leads to
an exponential loss in power
one simple example of this is a bit
stupid example
for reasons that i will explain
presently but still instructive
is look at the pigeon on principle and
which says that
x i j means that pidgin i flies into
hole j and we have constraints
for every pigeon i saying that it gets a
whole j
and but we have n plus one pigeons and
we have only n holes and for every hole
we have the constraint that at most one
pigeon flies into this hole
and if we write this in the natural
pseudo-boolean form
but do a conflict analysis where we only
extract closer reasons
then it's not so hard to see that
the this uh encoding
and the closer encoding have exactly the
same propagation properties
so for an outside observer if you're
doing your conflict analysis
on clausal reasons you can't really tell
whether the input
is these are these linear inequalities
or the cnf encoding
which in turn means that if you're
running on the cnf encoding we have an
exponential lower bound
in in the seminal paper by hockey
so this shows that if you're doing
conflict analysis but on clauses
extracted
from your linear inequalities then this
can lead to an exponential loss in power
so why is this a stupid example well
it's a stupid example because this is
also
the lp relaxation of this problem is
infeasible so if you're a met person
a valid complaint is to say well i agree
that if i
were to run conflict analysis on this
this wouldn't be so great but i will
never run conflict analysis on this
because at the root node
node of the mip solver will solve the
lpa relaxation and will immediately
determine
that the problem has no solution this is
a fair point
and i can just say that there are other
more interesting benchmarks where it
seems that you run into similar problems
where we see that pseudo-boolean solvers
perform really well
but mip conflict analysis seems to
suffer from that it's too close to
resolution and suffer
from the same exponential lower bounds
that resolution do
how do you then branch
well you can look at so you you know
already that you've run your lp solver
you have a solution x star
and if you think about it it would be
nice to find a variable
x j such that when you branch
on xj being larger
than the value in the fractional
solution rounded up or
smaller equal than the fractional
solution rounded down
if both of these sub-problems provide
good increases in your lower bound
so here comes a difference as we talked
about before how you're willing to
invest in a mip context a lot of time
in making decisions so one thing that
map solvers could potentially
do as far as i understand even early on
in the search
you consider all variables
and you look at the possible branching
decisions and you solve
the all the sub lps and look at
what the gain is and only then you
decide
how to actually branch so
from a sad solving or pseudo boolean
solving point of view this is absurdly
expensive this will take
tons and tons of time but you certainly
do get
a very good decision
[Music]
another technique is to not quite do
this so this is
let's look ahead or as strong branching
one other thing you can do is that you
can compute
estimates of what these gains might be
uh not by actually solving the lps but
using information from the past
branching history and this is known that
technical term for this is that they're
using pseudocosts
and later on in the search so maybe you
do some some look ahead search in the
beginning
and later in the search you can use
these statistics to already look back
and use pseudocosts instead which
will be faster but less accurate and
there are also other statistics that mip
solvers keep about
the variables to really make intelligent
decisions
another difference from uh sat solvers
and pseudo-boolean solvers as we said
you don't go depth first
there's a flexibility in how you're
going to to grow your search tree you
could definitely go that first
and this will make your repeated simplex
calls really cheap because
you're just adding one bound at a time
and then solving
calling simplex again so you don't need
many pivots
or you can grow your search tree in a
more adaptive way you can focus on
improving the lower bound
which is known as best bound search and
the lower bound if you're a mid person
you talk about dual bounds or
you can focus on improving your upper
bound or your solution
which make people will talk about as
improving the primal bound
and this is known as best estimate
search
but even if you do best bound search or
best estimate search you can combine it
with so-called depth-first search
plunges
where you suddenly go deep for a while
to exploit
the game that you get from being too
able to run
simplex quickly with hot restarts for
related problems
you have heuristics for how to find good
solutions and
improve them to improve the primal bonds
so these are primal heuristics
let me just give one concrete example
that is known as
relaxation enforced neighborhood search
again the assumption is that you run
your lp solver you have
a lp solution x star and you look at it
and for all the integer valued variables
that have integer values already
you fix those okay and then you look at
integer valued variables with fractional
solutions you reduce
the domain to either rounding this value
up to the nearest integer or rounding it
down
so all of these variables now have a
domain size of two
and now you solve the new sub-problem
where the fractional solution variables
have domains of size 2.
and this is just one example of
something that is referred to as
fix and mip local neighborhood search
heuristics
interestingly if you look at it with
sats or pseudo-boolean glasses
this is actually turning your problem
into a zero one
integer linear programming sub-problem
which you could imagine then if you have
a really good pseudo boolean solver
lying around then maybe you could feed
this problem to pseudo boolean solver
and there is lots and lots more uh
we haven't even started talking about
everything that mips solvers do for
large
uh problems you might need to decompose
them
the buzzwords are branch and price and
column generation
another important concept is bender's
decomposition where you
sort of divide the problem up into the
integral part
and the the real part
and
[Music]
somehow solve these
parts somehow independently as it were
so i wasn't planning to
get into this so maybe i should just try
to get out of it and
and refer you to the literature for for
a better explanation
uh um but these are important techniques
especially for for
for large problems uh symmetry handling
can be important you can do it via
graph automorphisms somewhat similarly i
think to how it would be done for
instance
in some sat solvers or the commercial
solvers would have
more syntactic dedicated symmetry
detection
you can rewrite your problem using
extended formulations
introducing new variables and
constraints and extended formulations is
a beloved topic
in the theoretical computer science
community
so this is um is there are lots of
interesting results there
uh parallelization is important
for mip solvers to run on parallel
architectures
uh how to use restarts many other
aspects
what about correctness well so the
fastest
mip solvers use floating point for
efficiency reasons but that means that
you might run into rounding errors
so what can you do about this well you
can try to do exact mip solving
but such solvers tend to be
significantly slower and they don't
uh incorporate
the full range of of state-of-the-art
approaches for for solving mip
programs but so this means that actually
the the
commercial state-of-the-art solaris can
sometimes give
wrong results maybe because of rounding
errors maybe because of bugs
and this is just a known fact that
sometimes
map solvers will claim um
that problems will return a solution as
feasible that is not feasible
or sometimes it will claim optimality
when
in fact the solution is not optimal and
people in the know apparently
know how to feed like evil problems
to mip solvers to to increase the
probability that they give
wrong answers when this happens this is
fairly well documented in the literature
but it seems that
you know it somehow happens rarely
enough that these mip solvers are
very useful anyway or quite often maybe
you don't care about
exact optimal solutions you're happy
with the good enough solutions and maybe
map solvers uh provide this
but it certainly raises the question of
how you would get
provably correct results like we know
from the sat community that
proof logging is important to have
certified
results from solvers and this is just
something that map solvers don't
provide although as i said there is a
need for it
there has been some work on providing
proof logging
for map solvers
it seems that well it seems like it's
it's
it hasn't been successful enough to
actually be incorporated in practice
let's put it that way uh in contrast to
um i think the proof logging techniques
for sat solving that are in fact used in
practice
a challenge of course compared to sat
swelling i think one reason why proof
vlogging for sat solving might be easier
is that
sat solvers are in sometimes a
monoculture you have the
conflict-driven learning paradigm that
dominates everything else
in mip-solving you have a much wider
diversity of techniques how can you
capture all of them is it even clear
what a proof should look like what's a
good format
and the more advanced the reasoning gets
the harder it gets also to generate the
proofs
on the fly without incurring too much
overhead
so this is another like uh definitely a
a good
uh open research problem um
for for mip solving and also for for
suitable in optimization and for
mac stat solving to be sure how to
provide proof loading
other interesting questions that i think
are worth thinking about that are
related to mip
is how to find out how to do better
branching on general
uh integer linear constraints again as i
said this is related to the stabbing
pain
planes proof systems i i complain that
mip
conflict analysis is not very smart
an obvious question at least for zero
one interviewing you know
integer linear programs which is a big
and important subclass of
mip problems uh whether
we could borrow ideas from native
pseudo-boolean solvers to improve
on the conflict analysis
uh there's lots of room for improvement
for providing a rigorous understanding
of
mip solver performance i think it's
instructive here
to compare with the state of the art in
satsawing somehow
maybe accidentally we have had these
parallel developments in set solving
on the one hand and in computational
complexity and proof complexity in
particular on the other hand
where it turns out that proof complexity
almost unintentionally
provides explanations for what sat
solvers can do and cannot do
and provides for instance lower bounds
on say the resolution proof system or
the cutting planes proof system
tells us what we can expect from say
cdcl solvers or cutting planes based
pseudo boolean solvers and
based on such results we can also
develop interesting
families of theoretical benchmark
formulas
sometimes referred to as crafted
benchmarks
and computational complexity results for
them where we know
that these benchmarks might be hard or
easy for solvers
using such and such techniques so it
would be interesting to have something
like that for
for mixed interior linear programming by
understanding that it is basically just
missing and then um
perhaps the main reason why i'm standing
here and recording this video is
since map solvers in fact seem to be so
good could we maybe steal the best ideas
from them to make our pseudo boolean
solvers better
so this is what i want to talk about
next and this is also the
final topic or final sub-topic
in this pre-recorded tutorial
on pseudo-boolean solving and
optimization
okay so combining pseudo boolean solving
and
mixed integer programming what are the
pros and cons
of the different paradigms well one
thing
that i'm trying to pitch that you've
heard several times now if you're
watching these videos is that
pseudo-boolean soldiers really have a
sophisticated conflict analysis
using the cutting planes method here i
don't mean the cutting planes method as
described in branch and cut earlier in
in this part four of this tutorial i
mean the cutting planes method
as in the cutting planes proof system in
the proof complexity literature which is
something related but slightly different
anyway based on the cutting planes proof
system you can get very sophisticated
conflict analysis that is exponentially
stronger
than what cdcl sat solvers provide
but we know uh from experiments it
published in the literature
that sometimes pseudo-boolean solvers
just perform abysmally bad
well we know that they're bad on cnf
formulas but more interestingly in this
context
because mip solvers also tend to be bad
on cnf formulas
but we know that mip solvers are
fantastic when the lp relaxation is
infeasible but we have
examples of pseudo-boolean problems
where the lpa relaxation
is infeasible but the sudo boolean
solver seems to run forever
not pigeonal principle formulas they're
typically sold very fast but there are
other
instances other other
benchmark families which which seem to
be really really hard
so mixed integer linear programming
solvers as we've seen now they have very
powerful search
um do a lot of smart thinking before
branching
exploiting information from lp
relaxations which is something that
sudubunos always just don't know about
they have a rich variety of of cut rules
not just division or saturation but
but mere cuts and other cuts
but on the other hand the conflict
analysis is not so great it's
basically just set-based
conflict-driven clause learning and it's
not clear
since they're so good at other things
like why would the conflict analysis
comparatively speaking be so weak
so the proposal then uh
presents itself to merge pseudo-boolean
solving and mixed intra-linear
programming to get the best of both
worlds
the sat style conflict-driven search and
conflict analysis and mip style
branch and cut and lp relaxations and
design a new solver to rule them all
so how would you do this so let me tell
you
one way of doing this and try to explain
why this might not be so easy so so
one idea would be to to i'll think so
since i'm coming from the side i'll
think of the pseudo boolean solver as
being in charge
it's another interesting perspective you
can think of the mip solver as being in
charge
and then using a pseudo boolean solver
as a subroutine that's a very
interesting perspective
um we won't talk about this in this talk
so this will be a separate talk so
let's think of the pseudo boolean solver
being in charge but
doing just as a mip solver would do call
the lp solver to solve lp relaxations
okay for instance you could use it as a
preprocessor but using it only as a
preprocessor is clearly not
sufficient because
it could be that the lp relaxation is
feasible
but we know of formulas where it's
feasible but they're sort of
back doors to lp in feasibility that is
you just have a small if you just set a
small number of variables
then the residual pseudo boolean formula
turns infeasible even as an lp
and still such benchmarks seem to be
exponentially hard for sulu boolean
solvers
so you somehow need to really integrate
the lp solving inside
the sudo boolean search so the other
extreme would be well
why don't you consult the lp solver
before making a decision
just as a map solver would do and the
answer is well you can't because you
don't have the time
so pseudo boolean solver is just the sat
solvers are based on this
very very quickly alternation of
decisions and propagations
and solving an lp relaxation is just a
completely
different time scale so if you solve an
lp relaxation
at every uh every time it's it's it's
time to make a pseudo boolean solver
decision
then the pseudo boolean solver will just
grind to a halt
and all the time will be hogged
by the lp solder so you don't want to do
this so somehow you need to
balance the time you set aside for
pseudo boolean solving and lp solving
that's one challenge
here's another challenge suppose that
you run the lp solver
and you know a dream scenario would be
you're somewhere in the middle of your
search the pseudo boolean solver is
happy
uh thinks it's doing good but then you
call the lp solver
and the lp solver says well given these
decisions that you've
already made dear pseudo-boolean solver
the residual lp is in fact already
infeasible so you can safely backtrack
what should we do if the lp solver says
this well
we should clearly backtrack i mean if
there is
no real valued solution in this subpart
of the space then clearly there's no
boolean solution
but a pseudo boolean solver can't just
backtrack you know
what can it do well it only knows how to
do conflict analysis on a violated
pseudo-boolean constraint and the
problem is of course there is no
violated pseudo-boolean constraint
because
because if so the sudo boolean solver
would have initiated conflict analysis
so the the lp solver sees a conflict
that the pseudo boolean solver
doesn't see and so it can't do conflict
analysis
more subtly this efficient lp solver
is using floating point so when it says
that there is a conflict the
pb solver can't just backtrack because
maybe this is a rounding error
and the
pseudo boolean solver must maintain
sound reasoning so how can you combine
this with using an lp that might give
floating point buggy results
a third interesting question is
okay suppose that we run the lp solver
and we do some kind of branch and cut
so that when the lp relaxation is
feasible
and the mip solver or the lp solver
finds the solution
then what a mip solver would do it would
generate cut constraints
so we can do this should we
tell the pb solver about this should the
suitable installer get access to
to these constraints and in the other
direction
uh the suitableness already is learning
new constraints all the time from
conflict analysis and
if you look at these constraints with
the right classes these are in fact
also kind of cut constraints a
particular kind of cut constraints this
can be made
somewhat formal and the question is well
should we pass on these cuts from the
pseudo-boolean solver to the lp solver
and
to tighten the lp polytube
and how so
we have a recent paper
joined with ambrose glexner
who's heading the skip team in berlin
um skip is arguably
the best academic map solver
so we have a paper where we tried to
integrate
a pseudo boolean solver with an lp
solver and cut generation and everything
so i'll tell you some of our ideas how
we did this
and what we see
so we interleave
lp solving within the conflict-driven
pseudo-boolean search
but importantly we keep track of the
total number of pivots
done by the simplex algorithm and we
enforce that this should never exceed
the number of pseudo-boolean conflicts
or rather that when we're thinking about
whether to call the solver
we will never issue an lp call if the
number of pivots exceeds the total
number of conflict seen so this is like
a proxy
for balancing lp time and pb time
once we call the lp solver we also have
a limit for how many
pivots we allow in a single
lp call because it turns out that if you
run the
lp solver until completion then some lps
can in fact be pretty hard and
the lp solver is operating on a
different time scale so
um maybe the instance will time out
without the lp
solver ever returning to the pv solver
and we don't
want that so then we just we have a hard
limit so we abort
after say p pivots in a single call
however this call is like wasted because
the clearly the lp solver did something
but
didn't reach any results and we don't
want to waste resources
so whenever this happens we double the
limit p
what this means that in the future we'll
get
fewer lp calls but we have a greater
probability
of the calls we actually make running
until completion
and i it seems that this is a novel
contribution to how you would
uh balance uh lp time
with uh with the other
techniques used in the solver because
the idea so i didn't say this but it's
just
the idea of somehow incorporating lp
relaxations in say a sat solver or a
sudobu
solver or even a constraint programming
solver
is certainly not a new idea people have
tried this but
a challenge
that has been hard to to
deal with is apparently the fact that
how do you avoid the lp solver to
to starve the other solver
and and this is how we make sure that
the lp solver can never
starve the sudo boolean solver
so what should we do when the lp solver
reports that the lp relaxation is
infeasible well
it turns out that this is this problem
has in fact been solved so you can use
farkas lemma which says that when this
happens
you can there exists and not only exists
but you can
find explicitly efficiently a linear
combination of constraints
that is violated by the assignment that
the solver currently has
and since this is a linear combination
of existing constraints a positive
linear combination of existing
constraints
it's valid to derive it so we can derive
this constraint
and add it to the database of
constraints for the solver and say
then we say ha we have a conflict
look pb solver we have a conflict here
and then okay then the pbsolver knows
what to do it can trigger conflict
analysis
and backtrack
importantly
when we compute this linear combination
we do so with
exact arithmetic so we don't have any
rounding errors
on the other hand if there were rounding
errors one thing that can happen
is that this linear combination that
should be violated
by the solver assignment turns out not
to be violated after all
we would not expect this to happen very
often but it could happen
well if so we just say we we determined
that this was a false alarm and we
ignore it and we continue the
sudo boolean search no harm done maybe
we missed out
an opportunity on an opportunity to
backtrack but
if so what we we try to compute
a constraint justifying this
backtracking and we fail so we have to
continue the pseudo boolean search
when the lp solver does not detect
infeasibility but instead finds the
solution to the lpa relaxation
we explore adding
cuts as a mip solver would do and
we share also these constraints with the
sudo boolean solver
to hopefully improve the pseudo boolean
search
we've also explored to some extent to
use
this lp solution to guide the pb search
like you can use it to maybe decide
which variables to to decide on or how
to set the face
and we've also in the other direction as
mentioned you could imagine having the
pseudo boolean solver passing on
additional learned constraints to the lp
solver
we've done some work on this as well
um so since i mentioned farkas lama let
me just be clear on
what we uh need so let me state like a a
very
special purpose pseudo boolean farkas
lemma which is
basically just farkas lama for zero one
interlinear inequalities phrased in sudo
boolean language that's all that it is
nothing fancy
so what it says is that if we have a
pseudo boolean formula
consisting of constraints c1 up to cm
and we have a partial assignment
rho such that when we apply
this partial assignment row to the
formula f and this is this notation
this is the residual formula f after
we've applied rho and simplified
suppose that you take this formula you
take the lp relaxation of it suppose
that it's infeasible
well then there are positive or
non-negative integer coefficients
so that you can find a linear
combination
of these constraints such that this
linear combination is in fact violated
by rho or
in pseudoboolean language if you take
this linear combination this constraint
and you look at the slack under row then
it's negative
and this is nothing new it's been
observed before that you can do this
and that the focus constraint that you
get in this way is a valid starting
point
for pseudo boolean conflict analysis
as we discussed before um
so the point is to somehow to do
conflict analysis
combined with lp relaxations and if
you're a mid person you can say well
we already have this mip solvers already
combine
lp relaxations with uh conflict analysis
skip does it some close source source
commercial solvers do it so so what's
the point why should we reinvent the
wheel
so it's important here to understand the
similarities and differences
i talked a bit about this before but let
me return to this again and
to describe in mit language as it were
how sudo boolean search and conflict
analysis works
so what's sudo boolean search so
we make a decision for some free
variable to assign it to either zero or
one
once we've done that we propagate all
assignments that are immediately
implied by some linear constraint and
if we get such a propagation then we
check if there are any other
constraints that are now implying other
propagations
and in order to we describe this in in
part two of the tutorial we use this
notion of slack
to decide propagation but this is just
the slack is just the formal definition
for saying
well a linear constraint propagates an
assignment if
setting the variable to the other way
would provably violate the constraint
so you do this until saturation
if there is no contradiction you go back
to step one make a new decision and then
propagate
so pseudo boolean searches this cycle of
decision and propagations
until you get a contradiction you get a
constraint that is violated then we do
conflict analysis now the fun thing
starts so what do we do
this is a somewhat simplified
description but it's close enough
so we so we have a conflict
so we look at the conflict in constraint
c
chronologically we look at the last
variable in c that was assigned to the
wrong value
leading to c being violated that was
because of a
propagation so we find the reason
constraint responsible for this
let's call it r
then we apply a cut rule
to r to generate a constraint that
propagates x to
a boolean value not only so so
the reason that r propagated was
that the pseudo boolean solver knew that
x had to be zero or one
but we change in the r cut constraint we
changed it so that
even if the solver would have been a
real valued solver it would still have
propagated all the way to zero or one
and there's a systematic way of of
making sure
um that this is so and this is covered
in part two of the tutorial
good so now once we have this we can
since our cut is still propagating x to
one value
and c would like x to have the other
value
it's not hard to see that x actually
appears with opposite signs
in r cut and c
so this means that we can take a linear
combination with positive
coefficients of r cut and c so that x
vanishes so let d be the smallest such
integer linear combination now you can
prove
if you think about it for a little bit
offline that
if we take the current truth value
assignment the current trail of the
pseudo boolean solver and we remove
x from it then this new constraint d
is actually still violated so this is
this invariant that we have in conflict
analysis that the constraint that we
have derived
is violated by the decisions made
before this point so we look at d
and if we like it if it satisfies our
termination criterion if it is assertive
then we say oh let's learn this
constraint
otherwise we say that
c d is our new constraint on the
conflict side
so we set c to d and go back to one
again and find
the next variable in in reverse
chronological order that was propagated
to the wrong value we find the reason
constraint for that
and and generate the new r cut
and take a linear combination of r
and c which is now d and keep going
until we get a d that we like when we
get a d that we like
we learn it meaning we add it to the
database
of constraints that the solver maintains
and then we
back jump we undo further assignments
that the solver had made
up until the first point where d is no
longer violated
and then we switch back to search so
this is how sudo boolean conflict
analysis
works if you want to describe it in in
mip language
how does this compare to what
skip and the other mib solvers would do
so
skip has the same propagation as pseudo
boolean solvers but in addition it has
the powerful but slower
propagation coming from solving lp
relaxations and
figuring out things that follow from
such lp relaxations
but the conflict analysis is weaker in
the sense that we don't
perform the conflict analysis on the
recent constraints
instead we extract disjunctive clauses
from the reason constraints and perform
the conflict analysis
on those and now if you pull together
your standard papers
on cutting planes on resolution
and the paper making the connection
between resolution
and conflict dream and close learning
proving that
conflict-driven close learning conflict
analysis is in fact just deriving
making resolution derivations then it
follows from this
that conflict analysis on extracted
disjunctive clauses is exponentially
weaker than conflict analysis on the
linear constraints themselves
so that is why explains what are we
doing differently now
so we're having more stupid
propagation potentially except that
we're also using a little bit an lp
solver now so we're improving
we're going in the mid direction when we
get information from the lp solver
and the conflict analysis is better than
what a mip solver would provide
for the corresponding zero one integer
linear program
another point to make is that again skip
uses floating point
whereas all the reasoning step in a
pseudo boolean solver would be exact
so there's no rounding problems with
rounding
so this thing that i described now
we implemented it we took the rounding
sat
sudo boolean solver and
combine it with the lp solver
supplex from skip and then we
can just run we can just run the lp
solver
[Music]
with inside the pseudo boolean solver
without anything else
or when it finds feasible solutions we
can generate
gomori cuts we can also
and share these gomori cuts with the
pseudo boolean solver
we can also in the other direction uh
share
uh learned sudo boolean solver
constraints with the lp
and here are some plots on what happens
so if we take
the collection of
hard knapsack benchmarks collected by
passenger
and we run the state-of-the-art sudo
boolean solvers
naps and set4j then we run
rounding sat and we run rounding set
with
lp integration plus komori cuts
plus also the pb solver sharing
learned constraints with the lp solver
and see what happens we see that
although these knapsack problems are
pseudo boolean optimization problems
set4j and knapp's struggle
rounding stat is better when you throw
in
the lp solver it gets even better
when you take the gumore cuts yet more
amazing stuff happened and even
sharing learned constraints from the pb
solver with the lp solver also helps
you don't get all the way up to skip but
you close a large part of the gap
so on these particular benchmarks it
definitely seems that combining pseudo
boolean solving with linear programming
is a no-brainer
then we also tried on running on some
pseudo-boolean competition benchmarks
some zero one intro linear programming
instances from mclip
again uh running just running sat
throwing in the lp solver plus gomorrah
cuts
plus sharing learn cuts from the pseudo
boolean solver side
with the lp solver
and we run on decision problems and
optimization problems from the latest
pseudo-boolean competition in 2016
and from some zero one
integer linear programs decision
versions and optimization versions that
we have adapted
from mid clip translated to
the pseudo-boolean format so these are
not quite the original mid-blip
instances
you have to see the paper for more
details
but anyway so
what can we see well
for all kinds of problems we see that
either the original mib solver or the
original pseudo boolean solver is best
however when
for for suitable in decision problems we
see that skip is actually pretty
terrible
and rounding sat is pretty terrible for
optimization problems and for myth
problems in general and here you see
that when you combine
running set with an lp solver you
interpolate
much more nicely you see that in fact on
decision problems
you're very close to beating the mips
over here
on suitable decision problems the the
mip solver gets beat decisively and it's
very close for the midflip decision
problems
[Music]
for optimization problems
there's even though rounding set cannot
beat skip there's a clear improvement
and then you can see interestingly you
see that on these types of problems
you don't gain too much from these
gomori cuts and learn cuts
but it's it's clear that in general
we're much
better than i mean this these
two columns represent the pseudo boolean
state of the art and we're clearly
improving
fairly significantly on that
so what are the conclusions i said that
we wanted to reach the best of both
worlds did we uh
not so clear in the sense that here
are still the best so we're not the best
of both worlds should have been in this
column or this column maybe but it isn't
but arguably as i said it's like uh
almost it's the
maybe second best of both worlds it's a
well-rounded performance we're never
much
worse uh than the best solver and that
is nice so it's like a
well-rounded good performance overall
always competitive with the best solver
and definitely i would argue fairly
dramatic improvements
for optimization problems compared to
previous
pseudo boolean solving state of the art
but again
skip is a hard to beat mip solver and
the commercial solvers
are even harder interestingly
we can see that adding lp solving
courses
causes a performance loss on pb decision
instances this is here go down from 1472
instances sold within the timeout limit
to 1453
so what happens it turns out
in particular the satisfiable instances
the results get worse
why is this well it turns out that if
you measure the search quality
in terms of the number of conflicts
until you
reach your satisfying assignment
the conflict count actually went down so
in that sense
somehow it seems that the search is
better but the search is also slower
so it doesn't pay off in terms of
running time the solver gets like more
intelligent but it's also
slower and this is gets back to this
theme that
um we talked about right at the outset
of this tutorial the the
trade-off between inference power and
inference speed here
apparently being a little bit dumber but
faster
is better
as we saw sharing these gomori cuts and
learn cuts
in general seems not to be so helpful
except for the knapsack benchmarks
where it's like absolutely crucial um
also i think that honestly uh this is
the
like i don't know of any pseudo boolean
so we're doing this before i'm not so
sure that we did this in the best way
possible in fact
i'm pretty convinced that there are lots
of smart things that could be done so
maybe the first thing to do would be to
to look at this more closely and
optimize how the sharing is done and
maybe we would see better
performance one thing we did look at
is to try to estimate how useful
different types of constraints are like
how useful are the regular constraints
learned from from pseudo boolean
conflict analysis how good are the
forecast constraints uh can we see any
difference between
regular constraints drawn from regular
conflicts compared to constraints that
we learned from these
lp initiated conflicts where the lp
solvers saw in advance that we're
heading towards the conflict and
gives us a focus constraint that allows
us to trigger conflict analysis
how would we measure usefulness well we
don't know what we can measure
is how often are these constraints used
in conflict analysis
so this is not necessarily usefulness
but it's at least usage
and hopefully tells us something
interesting
so at least i find it surprising
uh that or maybe not so surprising i
don't know but the
the focus constraints turn out to be
really useful
uh like we we
the the forecast constraint tends to be
much more used in conflict analysis in
the future than a regular learn
constraint would be
for optimization problems not
necessarily for decision problems
but the so these are the farkas
constraints that are returned by the lp
solver but then remember that we trigger
conflict analysis from these constraints
to learn a new constraint just as a
pseudo-boolean solver we do for
any conflict and these constraints seem
to be much
worse than regular learned constraints
and i don't know why
however there is also a big spread in
the usage
measurements but i think there there's
it would be interesting to
to study this and understand what's
actually going on
so future research directions uh well
fine-tuned heuristics think about
how to improve the cut generation based
on
our particular setting with sudo boolean
solving to get more intelligent in how
the sharing of constraints between
from the pseudo boolean side to the lp
side should be done
also one important thing is that we have
a very
in some sense a fairly static allocation
of time
by counting number of pivots that the lp
solver gets compared to the number of
conflicts that the pseudo-boolean solver
gets
maybe if the lp solver is is producing
amazing
results and deciding infeasibility over
and over again
maybe we should allocate some more time
to it
or on the contrary if it never does
anything useful then maybe we should
give it less time we haven't explored
this but it's a very natural
thing to try i think we talked about
which
constraints are useful forecast
constraints or uh constraints learned
from
focus uh conflicts
uh compared to regular constraints i
think there's more room for
understanding
um what's going on here also uh
to what extent like gomori uh cut
constraints are useful for the pseudo
boolean solver
um the mip solver uses lots and lots of
information
from the solutions to the lp relaxations
could we use this information more
intelligently also in a pseudo-boolean
solver since we're now
solving linear programming relaxations
pre-solving is something pre-processing
is not done in pseudo-boolean solvers
why don't we do that maybe we could use
mip-pre-solving
um maybe we could use uh
mixed into the rounding cuts instead of
the division we're using in pseudobull
and conflict analysis to improve it
i think this would definitely be worth
looking at i
to the best of my knowledge this has not
been done and as i mentioned before
in some theoretical sense we know that
mere cuts are never
worse than than division cuts they could
be better
but we don't know how much better this
is would be interesting to understand
so now we have combined an lp solver
with a
basic uh
pseudo boolean solver what about we
talked about in part three of this
tutorial we talked about core guided
search we talked about
implicit hitting set algorithm maybe
those could be
combined with an lp solver in the same
way
[Music]
a comment on the pseudo boolean
solver so it seems based on these
results that i showed here that rounding
sat with
linear programming integration or also
as
we discussed in part three of the
tutorial where core guided search
seems to provide state-of-the-art
performance improving significantly on
what has been available
previously for pseudo boolean solving
although again
pure mip solvers are also good and often
much better
but rounding sat tends to be much better
on unsatisfiable instances
or proving optimality than on actually
finding solutions
um so running on satisfiable instances
so it would be
very interesting and i think important
to improve the search
in pseudo-boolean solvers and
i believe that the sophisticated
cutting planes based conflict analysis
and pseudo boolean solvers
should be exported to make or at least
to zero one into the linear programming
solvers
and maybe we could go beyond zero one
uh integer linear programming solvers
and even solve zero one mips
in such a way that the pb solver would
be responsible for
the integral part and then whenever it
needs to deal with the real valued
variables
it would call an lp solver that takes
care of that
it would be interesting to see if
something like that could be could be
made to fly
so with this we have actually reached
the
end of the whole pre-recorded tutorial
all
four parts so trying to sum up in one
slide
pseudo boolean optimization is a
powerful and expressive framework
although we limited it to linear
sulubulen optimization but still you can
capture lots and lots of
problems with this and then once you
have
these problems formulated you can attack
them with with sat solving or max hat
solving or you can use
what i've referred to as native
pseudo-boolean solving that is
using pseudo-boolean reasoning based on
the cutting planes proof system
or as we talked about in this part of
the tutorial you can use mixed integer
linear programming
i think it's fair to say that these
approaches have complementary strength
so
i think it's an interesting research
direction to explore how to combine them
to exploit synergies
there are uh and and how to come up also
with new solving paradigms i think there
are
some highly non-trivial challenges in
how to come up with and design
algorithms and even more so
like coming up with a sophisticated
algorithmic idea is maybe not so hard
but then
implementing it to run blisteringly fast
in practice
is an important and and tough challenge
um on the theoretical side as i've been
trying to say today
especially for mixed integral linear
programming solving but also earlier for
these other paradigms max
sat solving for instance there are lots
of of
theoretical questions where we don't
really understand what's going on
there's
lots of room for for computational
complexity theory to
to contribute here i think but um
in this intersection in between
different areas i believe there might
also be quite a bit of low-hanging fruit
if we
come together if people come together
with different perspectives
and look at these problems then maybe
it's possible to
make significant progress just by
pulling ideas from these different
uh research areas and different
communities and and personally
regardless of anything else i just find
that these problems are really really
fun to work
on there's a they're an excellent source
of fun
problems both applied fund problems and
challenging theoretical problems
so um i invite you
to um work on these problems i'd be
happy to
uh talk to you if you're interested in
this and have listened
on the tutorial this far and with this
i thank you for watching and
and this is the end of the tutorial so
what
comes now is just the as promised
several times in these different
pre-recorded tutorials i'll just flash
through
the references but you should also be
able to find
the references in
the pdf file with these slides that you
you find on the simon's institute
web page as should be clear
from here there are
quite a few references for for
further reading with a focus
on on applied
papers and for some of this material
especially for the pseudo boolean
solving part you could also look at the
sat handbook the
the pseudo boolean and cardinality
constraints chapter and also the proof
complexity chapter which has
some of the latest news um
regarding how to design
conflict analysis algorithms based on
cutting plates
so i'll keep flipping through
these references i guess we're roughly
halfway um
and as you can see in particular there
are a lot of
max sat references um
[Music]
so i think there's a lot of material in
there
max at solving where you can ask
how these techniques can be lifted from
from conjunctive normal form to to the
pseudo boolean format
and maybe be made stronger
thanks to this
there are also a fair number of classic
sap papers like the serendire paper on
minimizing learned clauses
doing something like this in a for
pseudo-boolean solvers would be really
nice
and this
is the final
slide with references so
thank you again for watching this far
and
if you have any questions however after
having watched these videos
please do feel free to to contact me
shoot me an email
i'll be happy to talk thank you